hello and congratulations hi Perry thank
you I am going to kick it off with
probably the most serious question
you're going to get asked today but one
of my absolute favorite parts of this
movie is how Luigi is always there to
support Mario's goals and Ambitions even
when no one else will so I want to know
who is your Luigi in this crazy business
when you have a big idea or a dream who
do you know will always be there to back
it up that's a great question I love
that question that's that's a good one
Perry you're right
um it is hands down 100 my wife my wife
she is my creative partner my producing
partner my life partner she's everything
it no matter what I think whatever dream
I have if it's crazy or I think it's
crazy she's always there to tell me that
it's not she's always there to tell me
it's simply your dream and and she's the
one that is always there to tell me
listen you know whatever if you know
whatever story that you've made up is
why you can't do something
um why not think about why you can do it
is always what she says to me and it's
really really and it's been helpful in
my career it's changed my life my heart
right now I feel like I'm purposely
asking that question so I could take all
that motivation and put it in my own
back pocket after my crazy dreams
um so one thing I was reading a lot
about in the production notes is how you
got a whole lot of opportunities to you
know like really Reach for the Stars
when it comes to doing a voice
performance and that that was uh making
me wonder what would you say was I guess
your greatest reach or the biggest swing
you did when voicing toad that now we
can wind up seeing in the finished film
well okay that's a great one yeah the
biggest swing is was I going to be able
to get the voice as high as the Director
wanted it because as I was started doing
the voice there was Rhythm I had based
The rhythms of the voice on a friend of
mine and he liked that fine and then he
was just like but can you get the voice
Higher and Higher and Higher and every
time you'd say can you get it higher I'd
be like oh yeah here here we go and he
goes can you get it higher than that uh
yeah I think I can uh can you get it
higher than that
um yeah okay let's try it out and then
maintaining that and I'm going first of
all am I going to be able to maintain it
second of all is this really going to
work because you know you know you know
how like you hear yourself different in
your head than everybody else hears how
you sound and so you're just trusting
that it's gonna be okay and um and uh
and it worked out it worked out and then
I watched my interviews back and I hear
what everyone else hears and I just want
to like
all right so I was also uh I was reading
a lot about how you did a lot of improv
on this movie and it's all it always
makes me curious when it comes to making
an animated feature and doing improv
because I know there's so much
development that goes into play there's
a lot of moving parts so many
departments and different artists so to
kind of give us a sense of how much
improv you can really do what would you
say is the biggest difference between
the version of toad you were presented
when you were first offered the role and
how the character turned out in the
finished feature the biggest difference
would be I think that he has
um he's he's actually more of a
go-getter in the final version I got to
I got to be a little more contemplative
when we were when we were running it
because there was lots of stuff where I
would improvise I would make toad a very
kind of um for lack of a better word
loquacious person like he would talk and
talk and talk and talk which is just me
trying to get more screen time
um but and so I would improvise and
improvise and improvise but then
eventually we get to a point where that
all gets cut down to all just the
essentials and you find them being real
like a person he's like really a person
of action and um and that was something
that was great but I did get to
improvise quite a bit which was which
was fun
um the thing is that it's it's it's
easier it's a little easier now with all
the technology we have because you can
improvise something and they can go back
and reanimate something or additionally
animate something to match what you've
improvised it's true magicians back
there I'm sorry they really are the
movie looks incredible
um I have to leave I will say
congratulations again thank you for your
time and also thank you for always being
awesome in these interviews like
everyone says it you're you're always
like on point and really like lovely and
warm and thoughtful and I think a lot of
people appreciate it and you should know
oh thank you for saying that I
appreciate it